but you know who's in more trouble than
steve scalise
you know which politician is in much
hotter water these days
it's a ted cruz he's in the hot water of
cancun
the biggest controversy
biggest political scandal going on today
no don't you try to tell me about andrew
cuomo
covering up the elderly deaths in new
york that his policies directly led to i
don't want to hear about that
i want to hear about the most damning
serious political scandal that's going
on right now
ted cruz took his family down to mexico
for the weekend when the power was off
can you
it's so outrageous i
have refused thus far even to comment on
this stupid nontroversy
but now that it's a it's a big enough
story and senator cruz has
publicly talked about it so i guess you
know
if everybody's talking about it i might
as well do it too i have not spoken to
senator cruz uh since all of this went
down we haven't filmed a verdict show
we haven't talked about it so this is
just coming right off the top of my head
here
nobody cares about this nobody really
cares about this a lot of people
are pretending to care and a lot of
people are talking about
senator cruz flying to mexico during the
power outage
but nobody actually cares
which is why i haven't talked about it
until now
because i think this is an entirely
contrived
non-traversing a number of people
texted me when the big story broke that
cruz went to mexico for a few days
and they texted me because they know i
host show with senator cruz
and you know we're friends and so they
wanted my opinion on all of this
and i noticed to a person
who texted me the republicans who texted
me
were defending crews and the democrats
were attacking cruz
in other words the people who support
cruz
were still supporting him and the people
who hate cruz's guts
still hated his guts and nothing
actually changed you know senator cruz
has said that it was a mistake to go and
i suppose as a matter of optics
you know sure i guess that's that that
probably was a mistake i
i take his description of it and sure
fair enough
however does anybody really
think ted cruz was going to climb a
telephone pole with a wrench and start
what did they expect to happen that that
uh
he was going to dust off the windmills
or something no of course not
so he came back right away and he helped
out and he passed out water and
was assisting efforts uh okay that's
fine
but i don't want republicans to take the
wrong lesson
from the new york times attacking ted
cruz
this doesn't matter this doesn't matter
as a substantive matter
cruz could do exactly the same work from
an office in some hotel somewhere as he
could
from his house without power i guess
probably he could do more work right if
the power's on
and this won't hurt him politically i
don't think
i don't think this would hurt any sort
of republican politically i think
actually quite the opposite
i think when when the left is training
all of their sights on you it means
they're afraid of you i think that
they did this to donald trump for four
years and now the big bad orange man
is gone and moreover he's off of twitter
so they can't keep attacking him for the
things he's saying
and they're going to the next republican
and i don't think republicans should
back down from this kind of thing
i think that when the new york times is
going after you for a bunch of bs
it shows that you're doing something
right
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
you